[Música]
y
bien diferentes las reacciones de los
candidatos presidenciales tras los
acontecimientos de louisville kentucky
si viene donald trump no hacía
referencia a la figura de brión a taylor
pero si ensalzaba al fiscal general de
kentucky llamándolo una verdadera
estrella y ensalzando su labor por la
comunidad negra joe biden hizo
referencia a brión a taylor entendía el
dolor de la gente tras el fallo del
jurado pero pedía que no se actúe con
violencia
hubo tuits por parte de choam y de byd
en respecto a la primera noche de
manifestaciones en las que dos agentes
fueron heridos los dos hicieron
referencia al dolor de estos agentes y a
sus familias el donald trump por su
parte mucho énfasis en la ley y orden es
su gran objetivo durante todos estos
meses de disturbios y en cualquier caso
se van a ver las caras el próximo martes
en el primer debate presidencial que se
va a televisar y para el cual se están
preparando a ambos joe biden ha limitado
sus apariciones públicas y está
preparando este debate donald trump por
su parte está haciendo varios rallys
pero sin duda muchísima expectación por
este primer cara a cara
martes
[Música]
en california comienza a sentirse ya la
presión de esta campaña electoral sobre
todo en iniciativas que pretenden lograr
que la comunidad hispana se movilice
para acudir a votar también para
ilustrar lo importante que son estas
elecciones aquí en california también
hay otra iniciativa que quiere lograr
que los miles de sin techo que viven en
las principales ciudades de este estado
se registren también y puedan tener el
derecho a dar su voto ahora mismo en
general en california no hay una gran
incógnita sobre a quién se va a votar en
este estado ya que principalmente es un
estado demócrata la principal incógnita
está ahora sobre quién va a sustituir a
la senadora kamala harris si
efectivamente joe biden gana en
noviembre ahora mismo los ojos políticos
están puestos sobre kamala harris sobre
todo porque ella es parte del comité
judiciario que sería el que evaluaría el
candidato que trump pusiera para
sustituir a ruth báder ginsburg
[Música]
durante su discurso pre grabado ante la
asamblea general de las naciones unidas
el presidente donald trump dio un paso
adelante en su campaña por su reelección
este próximo 3 de noviembre su discurso
parecía que iba más dirigido a los
votantes nacionales que a la comunidad
internacional
donald tram hizo una férrea defensa de
su gestión durante esta pandemia además
se hizo hincapié en que durante sus tres
años de mandato la economía
estadounidense había llegado a los
mejores niveles de la historia y se iba
a recuperar muy rápido de estas
consecuencias terribles de la pandemia
donald trump dijo estar con el pueblo
cubano y venezolano en un guiño a esos
votantes del estado de florida un lugar
clave para las elecciones del próximo 3
de noviembre y no quiso cerrar su
discurso sin volver a repetir que para
el américa está primero y que espera
reunirse el próximo año en persona con
los líderes mundiales en el marco de la
asamblea general de las naciones unidas
dando por hecho su reelección el 3 de
noviembre
[Música]